me llamo gader agua tengo 19 años soy
siria y desde hace 3 años vivo en el
campo de refugiados de chatila en este
campo creado en un principio para los
palestinos
gadir y su familia hallaron refugio este
lugar se dio a conocer por una tragedia
la masacre de cientos de refugiados
palestinos en 1982 a manos de milicias
cristianas libanesas
hoy el campo también acoge a sirios que
buscan una vivienda a buen precio pero
vivir aquí es difícil
cuando vine a el líbano jamás imaginé
algo así estaba desconcertada no creí
que fuéramos a vivir aquí este lugar me
da miedo no me siento segura le dije a
mi mamá que regresáramos a siria así
estuviera en guerra
para soportar esta ciudad de la
sobrepoblada de callejuelas estrechas
gad y retomó sus estudios también
descubrió su amor por el yoga gracias a
la ong británica al shamaa allí estudia
para ser instructora hoy se dirige a las
oficinas de alfama para dictar clases
este es el único camino que tomó porque
mucha gente lo toma solo camino por las
calles muy transitadas nunca voy al
interior del campo
gadir tienes cita con un grupo de
adolescentes una vez por semana la
práctica del yoga puede no ser
suficiente para mejorar la vida de los
refugiados palestinos o sirios pero
estos jóvenes alumnos esperan
impacientes sus clases
con éxito sea una fiesta aquí hay mucho
ruido nunca hay calma ni reposo uno se
va a dormir cansado y se levanta cansado
así es la vida en este campo en
cualquier campo por eso decidí practicar
yoga después decidió enseñarlo quisiera
dar clases no sólo en el centro de alsa
más sino también en otros campos de
refugiados en el líbano
a pesar de las dificultades en cádiz
sueña con sentirse una mujer realizada
le gustaría en un futuro viajar a la
india para ahondar en su conocimiento en
el yoga antes de poder regresar a siria